[Music]
to add color and freshness to the salad
marinade Chotu martyrs in olive oil with
shredded basil and lemon zest the lemon
goes brilliantly the salmon Salmons
fragrant just take those tomatoes even
further because this is a salad for
winter I want some of my ingredients to
be hot
after parboiling potatoes and green
beans i soda them together
when you think of salad nicoise you
think of a visual summer cellar the
exciting way of doing it now at
Christmas there's ever a really nice hot
[Music]
when all the ingredients are prepared
it's time to bring the dish together and
dress the serving plate the seat you're
dressing it's starting from the center
and working your way out
first of all crispy salad leaves just in
the center of your plate what we're
doing now is building a base I don't
want a flat salad I want to sell it with
energy excitement and more importantly I
want something that looks visually
stunning sliced a baby gem lettuce
hearts into wedges and lightly roll them
in the tarragon mayonnaise and this is
really important because in ten minutes
time this salad will still stay nice and
crisp buoyant exciting I'm more
importantly packed full of flavor
next I so Ted potatoes around the
outside I want the color now I want the
visual impact then I'm gonna sort of
interlink the green beans next add the
marinated smartos and some black olives
now for the exciting power removing the
eggs from Express they're cut that
little basil leaf is the crucial secret
because that's like a little blanket
that slides it out
fingers crossed out
and I want that yolk still nice and
creamy inside the saltiness from the
anchovy it's almost pureed at the bottom
of that egg and that nice fragrance
sweet basil almost like they've been
rolled in perfume delicious
and finally the salmon and just peel off
that skin well the Silver Slipper
carefully flake the salmon and then
drape it on the salad Alain
it's amazing salmon over see the
pinkness incredibly aromatic and more
importantly every slither or that salmon
and it tastes amazing and that was a
perfect salmon Nicoise for Christmas
[Music]